all right guys we're about to watch the
spider-man no way home trailer it just
came out i'm actually watching it on
twitter right now because it's the first
place that i'm seeing oh it just came up
on youtube okay here we go okay here we
go
the official spider-man no way home
full-length trailer
we're gonna watch this right now
and
let's freaking do it go
all right that little teaser in the
beginning here we go since i got bit by
that spider
i've only had one week
he mentioned getting bit by the spider
just felt normal
that was when you found out
whoa
that looked
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
oh come on come on
universe
oh
dude
that suit looks sick
hello peter
oh actual footage
you're not peter parker
no way i'm sorry what was your name
again dr otto octavius they're in the
cell
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so scooby doo this crap
you're a mess i know a couple of magic
words myself starting with the word
please please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the dark jj
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
no way
i'm sorry kid
don't
you took it yet oh man
look there has to be
they're a danger another our universe
we're not going to take this hey jeffy
fox
you're struggling
let's film the
while the phone tries to make you choose
lizard say this
i can't save everyone
[Music]
yo this is just like gwen
what's happening
they're starting to come through
and i can't stop them
[Music]
december 17th
tickets on sale november 29th spider
monday
spider monday
oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh they showed everyone they
showed well not the sinister six the
sinister five they showed
everyone and oh my gosh they did not
show toby and andrew but they really
really hinted mg falling that was just
like gwen except i'm gonna assume
zendaya mj doesn't die wow okay that was
insane i love it i actually like that
they didn't show toby and andrew i want
to wait for the movie to see that i want
to see that for the very first time on
the big street but let me know what you
thought about this following trailer i
this is this trailer was fantastic i
loved it i love seeing all the villains
i love him saying dog och you're not
peter that would that blew my mind but
let me know what you think about this
i'm gonna get working on my breakdown
right now i love you all be sure to
subscribe hit that notification bell so
you don't miss out on the breakdown
coming right up for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you so much for watching
woof